[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin ihnen allen guten abend mit
mir im studio für den sport ist wieder
rudi cerne hallo schönen guten abend und
das sind einige unserer themen an diesem
donnerstag
kein abflug unter dieser nummer wegen
pilotenstreiks fallen morgen rund 800
lufthansa flüge aus über 100.000
passagiere sind betroffen
höhere kosten für reisende tank rabatt
und neun euro ticket gibt es nicht mehr
helfen soll eine energie pauschale von
einmalig 300 euro
und nervenkrieg um sapporo kontrolleure
der internationalen atomenergiebehörde
besuchen das umkämpfte atomkraftwerk in
der ukraine
[Musik]
ausgelöst durch massive personalengpässe
war es für sehr viele flugreisende ein
sommer zum vergessen zu dieser chaos
geschichte kommt jetzt ein weiteres
kapitel denn morgen streiken die
lufthansa-piloten grund ist der
festgefahrene streit über den
tarifvertrag
die rund 5000 kapitäne und co piloten
wollen 5,5 prozent mehr gehalt außerdem
einen inflationsausgleich ab dem
nächsten jahr das bietet die lufthansa
eine monatliche erhöhung um pauschal 900
euro laufzeit anderthalb jahre
unzureichend sagen die piloten und darum
jetzt also streik der auch viele
urlauber trifft isabel de la vega schon
wieder werden sie nicht fliegen können
abermals heißt es stornieren umbuchen in
der servicehotline hängen oder am
flughafen warten über 130 tausend
passagiere der lufthansa sind von den
flugstreichungen morgen betroffen vor
einem monat waren es viele auf dem weg
in den urlaub nun trifft es auch
rückkehrer nicht alle haben verständnis
für den streik ich denke dass andere
auch betroffen sind von der inflation
das ja der grund warum die streiken
ich denke andere leute hätten es nötig
als piloten also es ist zwar ärgerlich
für die passagiere aber es ist
verständlich für
das personal klar ist die
arbeitsbedingungen jetzt natürlich im
vergleich zu manch anderen
wenn ich doch sehr gut deswegen
hält sich dann mein begleiter grenzen zu
sagen die belastung sei groß die
mitarbeiter hätten viele zugeständnisse
in der korona flaute gemacht um den
konzern zu retten jetzt aber schreibe
die lufthansa wieder gewinne urlauber
wolle man nicht absichtlich treffen
es wird immer gesagt der zeitpunkt ist
ungünstig für die die gerade fliegen ist
das auch so dass es auch sehr
verständlich tatsache ist tarifpolitik 5
statt winter stattfindet jetzt sind eben
die tarifverträge ausgelaufen jetzt muss
stattfinden die lufthansa hat ein
angebot auf den tisch gelegt im
internationalen vergleich sei ist
großzügig
wir haben jeden piloten 900 euro mehr im
monat angeboten das ist eine gute
gehaltserhöhung insbesondere am unteren
gehalts land für die piloten 24 stunden
soll der streik gehen bis der flugplan
wieder normal läuft wird es sicher
länger dauern
peter wagner ist für uns am flughafen in
frankfurt peter worauf müssen sich
lufthansa kunden in den nächsten tagen
und wochen einstellen
ja nahezu alle flugzeuge werden morgen
am boden bleiben der 100 andere
passagier wird wahrscheinlich umgebucht
werden in der deutsch kann man auf die
bahn ausweichen aber am letzten
ferienwochenende in drei bundesländern
sind natürlich auch die züge prallvoll
die flugzeuge werden heute abend noch
dort geparkt wo sie dann samstag früh
wieder gebraucht werden damit der
flugplan weitestgehend reibungslos
wieder anlaufen kann dieses verfahren
hat sich bei den vergangenen streiks
sehr bewährt und davon kann man dann
auch hoffentlich ausgehen ja und wie
geht es dann weiter ich nehme an dass
sich piloten und lufthansa sehr bald
wieder an den tisch setzen werden und
dann diesen komplizierten tarif kosten
doch durchschlagen streiks sind teuer
das wissen alle sie sind sehr schlecht
fürs image auch für beide seiten der
tarifparteien und sie sind schlecht für
die bilanz und die lufthansa hat
durchaus schwierige zeiten und schlechte
zahlen zur zeit und das wissen alle und
deshalb die richter aus dass sich der
wald eine einigung einstellt peter
vielen dank für die aktuellen
informationen vom flughafen in frankfurt
wie soll ein drittes entlastungspaket
aussehen dass bürgern und der wirtschaft
in der krise hilft darauf soll sich die
regierung bis sonntag einigen fordern
spd und grüne man wolle noch vor der
haushaltswoche ab montag klarheit haben
so spd-chef mützenich fraktionschef
pardon die sozialdemokraten fordern
unter anderem direktzahlungen und ein
bundesweites 49 euro ticket
etwas ältere entlastungsmaßnahmen laufen
heute aus neue kommen hinzu zum heutigen
ersten september gilt eine
energiesparverordnung außerdem dürfen
sich viele wegen der rekord
energiepreise über ein trostpflaster von
300 euro freuen am spürbarsten dürfte
aber sicher der wegfall des neuen euro
tickets und der vergünstigten
spritpreise seien julia schröter mit
einem überblick
schlange stehen kurz vor knapp bis
mitternacht versuchten viele autofahrer
noch einmal den vergünstigten sprit zu
ergattern am morgen dann zeigt sich an
der zapfsäule das befürchtete die preise
sind nach ende des tank rabatt in die
höhe geschnellt die stimmung würde ich
nicht sagen ist nicht gerade rosig weil
ja die preise sind absurd mittlerweile
und schülerinnen das einzige was ich so
verdiene das geht halt für die
spritpreise drauf das tut schon weh
ebenfalls seit heute geschichte und das
neun euro ticket pnv ab jetzt wieder zum
normalpreis und mit tarifdschungel ob es
eine nachfolgeregelung geben wird darum
wird in der politik noch heftig gerungen
doch es gibt auch entlastungen um die
hohen energiekosten abzufedern bekommen
alle erwerbstätigen auch mini jobber mit
dem september gehalt eine energie
pauschale einmalig 300 euro porto
die heizung herunter gedreht wird ab
heute in öffentlichen gebäuden in
bibliotheken zum beispiel dafür die
nächsten sechs monate auf maximal 19
grad geheizt werden so schreibt es die
neue energiesparverordnung vor
geschäfte dürfen ihre kunden nicht mehr
mit offenen türen anlass ihre
schaufenster müssen nachts dunkel
bleiben auch bauwerke dürfen nicht mehr
angestrahlt werden all das gilt von 22
bis 16 uhr am folgetag
jetzt zum krieg in die ukraine die
inspektoren der un-atombehörde iaea
haben das russisch kontrollierte
kraftwerks afrika erreicht auf ihrem weg
von der stadt szabo richards um rund 55
kilometer entfernten akw musste die
delegation auf ukrainischem gebiet eine
zwangspause von mehreren stunden
einlegen wegen anhaltender kämpfe und
besonders heikel deswegen musste auch
einer der reaktoren kurzfristig
abgeschaltet werden hannah hebestreit
berichtet mit einigen stunden verspätung
haben die inspektoren der
internationalen atomenergiebehörde am
mittag europas größtes kernkraftwerk in
der russisch besetzten zone der ukraine
erreicht es muss dann alles sehr schnell
gegangen sein denn schon am nachmittag
äußerte sich iaea direktor grossi vor
den mikrofonen russischer medien
ich bedanke mich dass wir innerhalb
weniger stunden viele informationen
bekommen haben
das wichtigste was ich sehen musste habe
ich gesehen ihre erläuterungen waren
sehr klar die mission der
internationalen atomenergie- experten
sondern eine nuklear unfall verhindern
und den betrieb des kraftwerkes
sicherstellen also hier in der stadt sah
berisha gewinnen kann langsam den
eindruck dass die diplomatie im
mittelpunkt der inspektionsreise von
direktor grossi gestanden haben könnte
dann bereits nach drei stunden
inspektion der anlage bedankte er sich
und sagte er habe alles gesehen was er
habe sehen müssen offenbar ist die
mission für ihn schon fast wieder zu
ende für ihn und einem teil seiner
mitarbeiter nur fünf zu hören wir
bleiben noch für einige weitere tage
dort und werden dann die gelegenheit
haben gründlich zu überprüfen was sie
überprüfen wollen
weiteres ziel der eba ist die dauerhafte
präsenz am kraftwerk heute aber war
schon die anreise der inspektoren voller
hindernisse wegen schießereien lang der
route und rund um das kraftwerk mussten
die inspektoren mehrere stunden an einem
ukrainischen checkpoint warten ukraine
und russen beschuldigen sich gegenseitig
dafür verantwortlich zu sein
die ukrainische gegen offensive im süden
des landes läuft weiter das auch thema
ab 19.30 bei heute live der journalist
arndt ginzel berichtet was er dort
aktuell erlebte
seit jahren wird chinas führung
vorgeworfen das volk der uiguren in der
region shin chan systematisch zu
unterdrücken jetzt hat die un
menschenrechtskommission ihren lang
erwarteten bericht vorgelegt
hunderttausende uiguren und angehörige
anderer muslimischer minderheiten würden
willkürlich inhaftiert gefoltert und
ihrer fundamentalen rechte beraubt so
hochkommissarin bachelet china
bezeichnet die vorwürfe als lüge
heute vor 83 jahren begann der zweite
weltkrieg mit dem überfall nazi
deutschlands auf polen für die
erlittenen kriegsschäden drängt war
schon lange auf reparationen von berlin
und nennt jetzt auch eine konkrete summe
1,3 billionen euro diesen betrag
forderte der chef der
national-konservativen regierungspartei
peace kaczynski bei der vorstellung
eines gutachtens
die bundesregierung lehnt reparationen
ab polen habe in den 50er jahren auf
weitere forderungen verzichtet
und wir sprechen mit natalie steger für
uns in warschau natalie die polnischen
forderungen nach reparationen sind nicht
neu warum taucht das thema gerade jetzt
und mit solcher wucht auf
nun der tag heute hat einen hohen
historischen stellenwert symbolwert für
polen deshalb heute aber ganz nebenbei
hat die pis nun auch ihren wahlkampf
begonnen kommendes jahr sind
parlamentswahlen in polen und eins ist
klar das wird das top-thema werden
reparationsforderungen was wir hier in
den nächsten monaten höhe wir wollen
natürlich will die pi ist die eigene die
national konservative wählerschaft
bedienen aber man will auch wähler aus
anderen lagern rüberziehen denn immerhin
etwa die hälfte der polen ist für
reparationszahlungen also dieses leid
unter der deutschen das ist wirklich
tief eingebrannt in der polnischen seele
aber eins ist klar das wird ein langer
das wird ein schwieriger weg für die pis
das hat parteichef kaczynski heute
selbst eingeräumt klar ist und das ist
heute noch klar geworden denn je die pis
will das thema reparationsforderungen am
leben halten danke für die einschätzung
nach warschau und natalie steger
zuletzt fast in vergessenheit geraten
aber spätestens wenn es kälter wird wird
es wieder wichtiger das thema corona
heute hat die europäische
arzneimittelagentur grünes licht für
angepasste impfstoffe gegeben entwickelt
wurden die zwar für nicht mehr aktuelle
varianten helfen aber sollen sie auch
gegengerade kursierende mutanten so die
hoffnung schon nächste woche soll es mit
dem impfen wieder losgehen anna duda
bald kann hausarzt dr jur egal ob sie
verabreichen die omikron impfstoffe von
biontech und moderner angepasst auf die
sub variante baa1 sie wirken aber auch
gegen den wildtyp also das ursprüngliche
virus doch mittlerweile dominiert in der
eu die sub variante b a 5 das vakzin
gegen b a5 soll erst im herbst folgen
die patienten stehen jetzt vor der frage
boostern oder doch noch warten den
älteren patienten denen die risiken
haben den empfehle ich jetzt tatsächlich
sich impfen zu lassen
das ist jetzt genau der moment wir
warten jetzt nicht auf den impfstoff der
genau auf den subtyp auch noch
ausgerichtet ist die ständige
impfkommission wird zeitnah eine
empfehlung abgeben prinzipiell können
die neuen impfstoffe von bayern tag und
moderne eingesetzt werden bei personen
ab 12 die bereits eine
grundimmunisierung haben wir haben in
den klinischen studien mit dem baa1
nikon adaptierten bivalenten impfstoff
gesehen dass wir sehr ordentlichen
antworten bekommen gegen eine ganze
reihe von varianten die neuen omikron
impfstoffe sollen vor schwerer
erkrankung aber auch vor einer infektion
schützen zumindest vorübergehend der
jetzige im stoff hat das ja nicht
geschafft mehr weil diese omikron
varianten die sind hier nicht abgedeckt
aber neue impfstoff deckt eben diese
omikron varianten ab und somit rechnen
wir da auch wieder mit schutz vor
ansteckungen die ersten impfdosen
könnten schon in der kommenden woche in
arztpraxen und ins zentren verabreicht
werden
die menschen in der altenpflege besser
für ihre wichtige anstrengende arbeit
entlohnen seit heute ist es realität
denn es greift die verpflichtende tarif
bezahlung beschlossen noch von der alten
bundesregierung allerdings sind
patientenschützer nicht glücklich sie
warnen dass jetzt gleichzeitig kosten
steigen für pflegebedürftige angehörige
und pflegedienste betraut
sie kriegen jetzt endlich mehr geld bei
manchen könnten es ein paar hundert euro
im monat sein denn auch mitarbeitende
dieser privaten pflegeeinrichtung im
nordschwarzwald müssen jetzt nach
tarifvertrag bezahlt werden der
geschäftsführerin macht das neue gesetz
her komme natürlich sind wir auch für
eine gute faire angemessene bezahlung
aber was dabei immer vergessen sie das
ist die finanzierung dieser tariflöhne
wir müssen auf der einen seite mehr
ausgeben brauchen aber dafür natürlich
auch die einnahmen dh die politik klopft
sich auf die schulter aber es wird ganz
vergessen dass dies auf dem rücken der
bewohner ausgetragen wird den einen
gültigen tarifvertrag den gibt es gar
nicht stehen viele zur auswahl sie muss
einen wählen und dann mit den
pflegekassen verhandelten über mehr
zuschüsse doch dass die wirklich
einspringen das ist noch gar nicht
spruchreif die warten selbst auf ein
signal der politik wir fordern eine
gesetzesänderung die bedeutet dass auch
die pflegekassen entsprechend mehr
zahlen können damit diese mehrkosten auf
mehr schultern verteilt werden können
man glaubt es kaum aber im moment ist es
so dass die mehrkosten tatsächlich
nahezu alleine von den pflegeheimen
bewohnerinnen bewohnern finanziert
werden müssen die eigenanteile der zu
pflegenden werden deutlich steigen das
ist sicher und auch sie können sie nur
bedingt freuen über mehr geld die frage
irgendwann die fläche noch bezahlen oder
wer kann die fläche noch bezahlen
letztendlich steht da unsere
arbeitsplätze mit auf dem spiel eine
bessere bezahlung für pflegekräfte
längst überfällig nur die finanzierung
wirft noch viele fragen auf
und jetzt eine wirklich positive
geschichte über den einst wohl
dreckigsten fluss deutschlands es geht
um die emscher auf den rund 80
kilometern von der quelle in holzwickede
bis zur mündung in den rhein bei
dinslaken wurden vier kläranlagen gebaut
34 430 kilometer abwasserkanäle und drei
pumpwerke eine investition von 5,5
milliarden euro jetzt nach jahrzehnten
ist die emscher keine giftige industrie
kloake mehr sondern tatsächlich ein
stück natur mehr von thomas minder
das erscheint unglaublich wenn man die
alte emscher gesehen hat der fluss bei
castrop rauxel an die del mit fischen
enten und wasserpflanzen grüner muss es
erst noch werden aber mit der kittel
becke wie der nach dem krieg
schnurgerade kanalisierte fluss früher
nur genannt wurde hat das hier nichts
mehr zu tun seit 1990 wurde saniert und
entwickelt
das ist die große leistung dass ein
komplettes neues system im ruhrgebiet in
einem dicht besiedelten region neu
entsteht seit 80 jahren war die emscher
kein fluss sondern der größte
abwasserkanal des ruhrgebietes und der
dreckigste mit pumpwerken musste die
breite masse richtung dahin bewegt
werden dann 1990 begann der weg zurück
ist erklärt werke wurden gebaut viele
merkte man am anfang nicht davon
schwimmt also alles mögliche darum was
man also nicht so gerne sieht und nicht
anfangs toilettenartikel was weiß ich
binden alles mögliche was so in die
toilette geworfen wird das eklige
schließt zum beispiel bottrop ebel durch
da will ich groß geworden und da war im
sommer weimar dufte hast jetzt ist das
werk vollbracht die emscher wieder ein
fluss trinken sollte man noch nicht
daraus aber das komme noch heißt es und
alles innerhalb des geplanten zeit und
geld rahmens das begeistert wir sehen
daran and can be done
einige rest baustellen gibt es noch aber
auch die sollen bald abgeschlossen
werden den rest macht dann die natur
jetzt zum sport und rudi cerne bayern
münchen ist relativ souverän in die
zweite runde des dfb-pokals gezogen
genau und der klare angelegenheit und es
war ein standesgemäßer sieg der deutsche
rekordmeister gewinnt bei viktoria köln
mit 5 0 beim spiel gegen den
drittligisten gab trainer julian
nagelsmann auch spielern aus der zweiten
reihe eine chance die einer
vortrefflichen nutzte mattes l traf kurz
vor der pause zur 2 0-führung damit
krönte sich der erst 17 jährige
neuzugang aus frankreich zum jüngsten
pflichtspiel torschützen der bayern
geschichte
und die tor jagte selling holland geht
auch bei manchester city weiter beim 6 0
gegen nottingham forest traf der
ehemalige dortmund stürmer dreimal damit
erzielte der norweger seinen zweiten
hattrick binnen vier tagen er setzt neue
maßstäbe dabei ist auch in holland
gerade einmal fünf spieltagen in der
premier league der ehemalige torjäger
vom bvb freut sich bereits über neun
tore liga-rekord drei tore gelangen ihm
jetzt beim 6 0 sieg von manchester city
gegen nottingham forest durch einen
lupenreinen hattrick nur fünf
ballkontakte brauchte horn für seine
ersten beiden treffer in minute zwölf
und 23 noch vor der pause erhöhte der
norweger per kopf auf 3 0 das star
ensemble von pep guardiola mit earl in
holland bleibt mit 13 punkten
tabellenzweiter hinter dem fc arsenal
kaum jemand hatte ihr etwas zugetraut
nach schwachen leistungen im vorfeld der
us open doch nun steht serena williams
im letzten turnier ihrer beispiellosen
karriere bereits in der dritten runde
sieg gegen anne konter welt immerhin die
nummer 2 der welt
lust auf mehr
es ist fantastisch es steckt offenbar
noch einiges in mir wir werden sehen
wofür das reicht die 40-jährige mutter
bewegt sich noch immer mit
beeindruckender bucht und
geschmeidigkeit gepaart mit taktischer
finesse
wenn es optimal läuft werden die
tennisfans serena zum abschluss ihrer
karriere noch genau fünf mal umjubeln in
new york
da war was los
die zum wetter so viel heute hat der
meteorologische herbst begonnen details
gleich von christa oben wir empfehlen
das heute journal um 21 uhr 45 mit
christian sievers morgen hier an dieser
stelle barbara hahlweg danke für das
interesse schön donnerstagabend für sie
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen im herbst für uns
meteorologen hat er ja schon heute
begonnen werfen wir also kurz einen
blick zurück auf einen wieder mal zu
heißen und trockenen sommer der war
nämlich insgesamt 40 prozent trockener
2,9 grad wärmer und 34% sonniger als
normal und damit ist er der sonnigste
seit aufzeichnungsbeginn wir kommen zum
wetter heute nach dass es oft klar hier
und da mal ein paar wolken bei einem
frischen östlichen wind mit dem es
richtig gut auskühlen kann vor allem in
der osthälfte 12 bis 7 grad nur morgen
früh im westen ist es etwas milder mit
15 bis 12 grad auch morgen haben wir
diese temperatur zweiteilung im osten
eher herbstlich bei 20 bis 22 grad im
westen durchaus sommerlich mit 24 bis 28
grad das ist aber ein tag mit vielen
harmlosen quellwolken viel sonne und nur
einzelnen regentropfen an der ostsee und
einem frischen östlichen wind erst
abends werden aus südwesten die wolken
dann dicht es entwickeln sich schauer
und gewitter die am samstag im südwesten
dann durchaus richtig kräftig ausfallen
können der nordosten bekommt bei den
frischen trockenen ostwind davon
allerdings nichts mit und bis montag
wird es dann von westen und südwesten
wieder richtig heiß